the most comfortable men's boxers and
t-shirts you'll ever find are at leisure
of NYC their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers
feel as light as air and their silky
smooth supima cotton crewneck t-shirts
are amazing I love them you'll get 15
off with code Pacman at davidpackman.com
NYC I just absolutely love this story
I'm starting with today Colorado
election officials are formally ordering
a recount in Lauren bobert's
Congressional race which she won by 5
550 votes against Challenger Adam fresh
now if you look at the reporting they
say very clearly this is not expected to
change the result but this is so
fascinating because these people on the
right who just insist everything stolen
recount everything audit everything blah
blah blah blah blah now there's actually
a legitimate reason for a recount to be
ordered in a race that Lauren bobert is
of course extraordinarily relieved to
have survived because she almost went
down after just one term in Congress to
Adam Frisch so there's an article from
the Colorado sun and it says Colorado
elections officials formally order
recount in race between Lauren bobert
and Adam Frisch bobert leads Frisch who
has already conceded by 550 votes the
recount is not expected to change the
outcome of the third congressional
district race
this is a mandatory recount and it was
expected this was a closely watched race
bobert leads fresh the margin is 550 but
the law is that you must have a
mandatory recount when the number of
votes separating the two leading
candidates is less than half of a
percentage point of the number of votes
cast the margin is
0.3 percent meaning that the recount
must take place
the Secretary of State Jenna Griswold
who's a Democrat added the results of
the District 3 race reinforce the fact
that every vote matters Colorado voters
have made their voices heard I'm
ordering the recount in accordance with
Colorado law this can begin immediately
recounts rarely shift the margin margin
Beyond a few votes which is why Frisch
conceded in the closer than expected
contest the Third District leans heavily
in Republicans favor this is this is
just great so I don't think it will
change the outcome I believe Lauren
bobert really won this is still a
fascinating race because as the article
points out that Third District in
Colorado is quite a right-leaning
district and the fact that it came down
to 0.3 between an incumbent Republican
member of Congress Lauren bobair and the
Challenger Adam Frisch means that Maga
really isn't safe and we saw Madison
cawthorne defeated and removed from the
House of Representatives we'll talk
about him in the next segment and his
crazy outgoing speech but there is a
real question as to the viability of
Maga going into 2024 and just making
Lauren bobert have to wait a little bit
longer is a really great thing that I
can certainly get behind now when it
comes to 2024 we still don't know what
is going to be the level of strength of
these Maga candidates I think it will be
different if Donald Trump remains in the
race and becomes the nominee versus if
Trump remains in the race but loses the
nomination versus if Donald Trump simply
bails on the primaries because it's
looking so terribly we don't know which
of those three scenarios ultimately will
happen but if it's the ones that are not
so good for Trump this may be it for
these Mega people it we we will be years
removed from Maga in November of 2024
and it would be great if people like
bobert were removed and ended up being
just sort of a blip in American
political history cawthorne was removed
Marjorie Taylor green won easily Lauren
bobert won but by a very small margin
let's hope it keeps going in that
direction and listen Maybe the recount
will find that actually Adam Frisch won
but not expected to and I don't believe
that that will be the case is if we
needed any more confirmation that
Madison cawthorne being kicked out of
the House of Representatives after just
one term is a very very good thing I'm
going to present to you today exhibit
number 150 of why cawthorne using his
final speaking opportunity on the floor
of the house to rail against and I quote
here
soft metrosexuals
take a look at this clip this is a guy
who seems obsessed with gender stuff and
even cultural issues that aren't big
issues now I think it's been 12 years
since I heard the term metrosexual abuse
here is Madison cawthorne delivering
this final principled and defiant speech
on the floor of the House of
Representatives our young men
strength that delicacy is desirable and
that being a soft metrosexual is more
valuable than training the Mind Body and
Soul
social media has weakened us siphoning
our men of their will to fight to rise
in a noble manner Square their jaws and
charge once more into the breach of life
to defend what they love
so on this precipice of disaster I asked
the young men of this nation a question
will you sit behind a screen while the
story tales of your forefathers become
myth or will you stand Resolute against
the dying light of America's golden age
will you reclaim your masculinity will
you become a man to be feared to be
respected to be looked up to or you let
this nation's Next Generation be its
final generation that line about will
you become a man to be feared
you know
call me crazy
but I respect people
who Garner respect not who make others
afraid and in fact often those who make
others afraid
are quite cowardly people when it really
comes down to it and this is really you
know it's easy to say oh it's Madison
cawthorne with another one of his wacky
rants on his way out don't let the door
hit you as you as you exit sort of thing
but he brings up an idea or a concept
that is becoming increasingly common
among the right which is that fear is
they just love fear in every sense they
they see those who are feared as
powerful and to be respected they use
fear-based politics and fear-mongering
to get people to vote from for them oh
the you've got to be afraid of the
violent immigrants that are coming in
and you've got to be afraid of the crazy
Communists that have taken over Congress
and of course none of these things are
true
um fear is a big part of their politics
and Madison cawthorne just explaining an
additional way in which that's the case
now as far as the metrosexual stuff I
don't know that I've heard anyone
complain about metrosexuals since 2008
like yeah very very early in 2008 I
would even say and for people who maybe
don't remember or never knew what that
term meant metrosexual referred to
a young often Urban
heterosexual male
often with left-leaning political views
who's interested in fashion and has what
might be considered a refined sense of
taste and it was a way of criticizing
heterosexuals who you can't just say oh
they're gay by saying this is a brand of
heterosexuality that is sort of less
manly and less masculine again I haven't
heard metrosexual as a term used in a
very very long time but we clearly know
what is on Madison cawthorne's mind I
want to play some clips for you of Jim
Jordan
Jim Jordan is a republican congressman
and Jim Jordan is interesting because
he is sort of the epitome
of the I say a lot of stuff but when it
comes down to it I don't really stand
behind the principles and when it comes
to Jim Jordan often those principles
have to do with a small government
conservatism so-called small government
conservatism and the claim from the
right that oh we don't want to regulate
we don't we want to let businesses do
what they want to do Jim Jordan appeared
last night uh no the night before last
with Sean Hannity and he seems to be
saying here that Apple should be
investigated because they've stopped
advertising on Twitter that's pretty
that's pretty that's several levels deep
when it comes to getting pretty involved
in the decisions made by private
businesses take a listen to this I think
there's some other critical questions
Sean we got to ask like why did Apple
change the features on phones in China
why do that for the CCP and and I think
the the other the other key Point here
is why uh why is Apple no longer
advertising on Twitter some of their ads
have they gone woke so what I want to
know is where was the Apple where's the
Apple that a few years ago said we're
gonna stand up for Americans privacy
where's the Tim Cook who told Jim Comey
there is no way we're giving the FBI
backdoor access to people's phones
that's the Apple we want to see because
I again right now we know one thing Sean
the left is at war with the First
Amendment the left doesn't want the
First Amendment anymore and uh that is
that is the key concern here the left
now says this if you don't agree with
them you're not allowed to speak and if
you think there's think about how crazy
that is okay
these are people
who want to tell businesses
you're pulling advertising from Twitter
because you don't like Elon Musk we
should investigate that
that's their free speech right those
businesses have the right to express
themselves by advertising or not
advertising wherever the hell they want
and they have the gall and the audacity
to say it's the left that's against
speech understand that all of these
actions being taken by people related to
Twitter are protected by Free Speech if
someone wants to protest Elon musk's
ownership of Twitter by quitting Twitter
that is their constitutionally protected
Free Speech right whether it's because
they're woke or not doesn't really
matter if you want to Lobby
companies that you patronize to stop
advertising on Twitter because you don't
like Twitter that's your free speech
right if I see that you know whatever
what company you know Frameworks is
advertising on Twitter
and I want to go to Frameworks and say
Hey you shouldn't advertise on Twitter
because of this that the other thing
that's my My Free Speech right and if
Gator Works Frameworks sorry Gator
Frameworks this is my mic stand if Gator
Frameworks says oh we want to ignore
what our customers are saying and keep
advertising on Twitter
that's their right and if they say
that's that's kind of an interesting
idea yeah maybe or some of our customers
are right we shouldn't advertise on
Twitter that's also their free speech
right this is all speech
and they claim it is the left that is
suppressing speech these people are
pathetic and by the way this we should
they should be worried if they start
investigating Apple what will happen
with all the investigations into Hunter
Biden that they have planned one other
clip from this appearance two nights ago
continuing to talk about Twitter take
Twitter off the App Store so there's
some good news there is it maybe because
Elon Musk threatened to compete with
with Apple
yeah well I I probably so but it sounds
like that meeting went well today let's
we'll find out tomorrow so let's hope
they're not going to kick Apple out of
the App Store but I think
imagine if 10 years ago even eight years
ago I told you in 2022 almost 2023
Republicans are going to be on Fox News
doing segments wherein they say hey you
know what we got to make sure that
Twitter doesn't get kicked out of
Apple's App Store and if they do we
might just have to investigate that
these people are truly something else
it's all small government it's all small
government make sure that you are
subscribed to the YouTube channel at
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show
we're going to take a quick break and be
back right after this
one of our sponsors today is Leisure of
NYC offering Ultra comfortable fair
trade men's clothing at a fair price
guys know how tough it can be to find
good boxers and t-shirts the Search is
Over All boxer briefs by Leisure of NYC
are made with amazingly soft moisture
wicking viscose from bamboo it feels
super lightweight like air it doesn't
Bunch up it's also great for the planet
Leisure of NYC also makes these
incredible supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts for men less than one percent
of men's Basics today are made with
supima cotton it's the best out there it
feels like Silk quite frankly you can
walk around in a scratchy t-shirt all
day or you can enjoy the cloud soft feel
of supima cotton and actually love the
shirt you're in these are my go-to
shirts and boxers nobody else even comes
close to the Comfort they provide all
products are fair trade with
sustainability in mind pick some up for
yourself or someone on your holiday
shopping list go to davidpackman.com
NYC and you'll get 15 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below the David packman show depends on
your support we are a viewer listener
Community audience supported program we
make it very very easy to support the
work we do you just go to joinpakman.com
that's really it it's simple it's quick
it's easy and you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now 24 starts now to get
yourself a discount we are going to hear
from the most important people in our
ecosystem
the viewers the listeners the audience
if it weren't for you there would be no
show I would probably still own a
microphone but I wouldn't be able to do
anything interesting with it that's for
damn sure we take calls via Discord at
davidpackman.com Discord The Waiting
Lobby is where you go if you want to
chat with me and let's see the degree of
technical problems that will plague us
today I want to start here with Alex
from Baltimore Alex from Baltimore uh
welcome what is on your mind today
hey Dave can you hear me yes I can
alrighty so first question I've been
meaning to ask you
anyone who listens to your live calls
and live streams knows you're very
particular about your bagels so as
someone who's a little more vagal
illiterate for lack of a better term
what makes a David packman approved
beggle
well you need the right ratio of crunchy
on the outside and pillowy soft on the
inside it's it's almost an ethereal
thing that's beyond description you just
need to bite into it and you know right
away
okay and it doesn't matter like the
topping of bagel or is this I mean
listen uh you're not gonna see me with a
french toast Bagel anytime soon of
course the topping matters absolutely
the the really if you're looking for a
sweet Bagel you go cinnamon raisin but
all of these you know strawberry Bagels
French toast oatmeal pancake Bagel
chocolate chip no no no no it's not for
me I'm a purist
now I agree uh Savory bagels are better
than sweet Bagels I would say I would
say so okay all right uh real question
so this is based off of a book I read
recently
um
would you say is do would you give any
ingredients to the idea that
the president of the United States just
flat out has too much to handle and that
no matter who it is
what their uh beliefs are they're just
gonna have a hard time and they're not
going to be particularly good at their
job no I don't agree with that I mean I
think there's sort of two different
questions here there's the question of
does the president of the United States
have too many responsibilities in terms
of Delegation and then there's the
separate question of whether they're all
going to be bad at their jobs I think
that there are lots of presidents who
were good at their jobs I mean President
Obama was good at his job you never got
the sense that he just couldn't keep up
with all the different things that were
under his purview I think the more
interesting question or maybe the more
accurate
assessment that could be made is they're
they're simply need to be
significantly more diplomats because as
we know a lot of these issues they touch
the presidency but then they are the
details are sort of handled by the
diploma attic core that the Diplomatic
course should be bolstered and should be
bigger I think that's a fair assessment
to make but of course the right says we
need the smallest possible government so
by definition they're against enlarging
The Diplomatic Corps
gotcha and uh the book is uh the hardest
job in the world by John Dickerson who's
on CBS actually yeah it was actually it
was actually an interesting book that
wasn't his only point it was also like a
mini history of the presidency and how
even like mundane responsibilities like
evolved and kind of pile up on on their
day-to-day and make the job a little
harder another slight thing they he said
was uh
how the President also has to be a great
campaigner and great at governing and
that a lot of people can't
aren't necessarily the best at doing
both like I'm sure there's a bunch of
senators it would be great presidents I
think of a
Amy Klobuchar or a um
on Elizabeth Warren but who on The Stomp
just don't seem to impress anybody so
but they would be great once they got in
the chair I would go even further
there's there I completely agree there's
people who would never even run because
the idea of the political campaign is so
off-putting to them who would still be
really good presidents if they somehow
ended up in that position so I
absolutely agree with that
yeah and that was just a
that was just a good point I thought all
right well that's all I had I will talk
to you next time all right thank you
very much for the call I appreciate it
let's go um let's go next to Harry from
Columbus Ohio Harry welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
David this next one to be talking to you
can you hear me all right I can hear you
thank you
um first I wanted to mention that you
said on a recent bonus show that you
wanted to buy some sort of sign for the
back of your car to talk to other
drivers and this is a fantasy iPad as
well
um but I would heavily advise against it
because I cannot think of a faster way
to get shot on the freeway
so definitely definitely don't buy that
if applications available please yeah my
my idea was you know the particularly
the texting and driving is such a
Scourge to society
from miles away on the highway you know
you see someone going 10 under in the
fast lane you know they're on a phone
and so I have this fantasy that as I
unfortunately have to pass them on the
right because they give me no choice you
get behind you know it's like they don't
even know how to use a highway as I pass
them on the right
I would have in my window I would just
pull up next to them and have this led
sign that would I could like type with a
keyboard or something and it would say
get off your phone get out of the fast
lane and that they would learn I'm
acting like an idiot and then they would
move over and everything would be great
but you're probably right that it
wouldn't really work out in that way
yeah I imagine you know people would buy
these signs and there'd be like sort of
you know a race war or a racing war
between getting in front of each other
to swap messages like no you turn this
no you're doing that well I think it
would be effective on the side window as
much as in the back windshield you know
okay so to my real question so do you
have any sort of advice for somebody who
is currently at no reading of books I I
never really got into reading in high
school I was into Reddit into reading
news articles but like do you have any
sort of advice for like how to get
started in Reading because when I try to
sit down it sounds like the issue is
because you haven't regularly been
reading for a while you wouldn't even
really know where to start in terms of
what types of books you would enjoy
yeah I mean that's a good way of putting
it sure okay what topics are generally
interesting to you or what what movies
or TV shows or have you seen a
documentary that that you liked what
sort of things are you into
I think the main thing is that I don't
want it to be a waste of time right like
I already I have such such little time I
wanted to be books where I'm taking in
the maximum amount of learning about um
I I think recent American political
history would probably be like the
greatest interest to me just like okay
you know
and your recommendations about because I
don't read those types of books at all
so my suggestion would be go to a
website like Goodreads and then just
search through some of the
recommendations and the highest rated
stuff I'm sure you'll find things that
are interesting to you
well you don't have any sort of
recommendations for like any yeah like
what what types of maybe authors in
general to look for maybe
for hello
okay
we just lost them okay I I don't read
that genre so I don't know but there
will absolutely be recommendations I
would I would consider checking out
Goodreads okay let's go to Daniel from
Maine Daniel from Maine welcome to the
program what's on your mind today and I
see that you are self-muted if you
unmute yourself you will be able to talk
to me Daniel from Maine welcome
you hear me yes
excellent uh first time caller uh I'm
actually shocked I was called on uh I'm
as shocked as you are to be honest
excellent uh so I've actually been a
viewer for a really long time
um about 10 years now actually so
pretty crazy yeah I started watching
when you still had Lewis on the show I
saw Lewis last night you know we played
we went to trivia and we were second to
last unfortunately
oh okay well that's that's pretty cool
uh anyways so I guess my question today
is what I guess how do you keep yourself
from not going insane with with what you
do
um you know I
when I watch you break down clips of
these insane you know Mega Republicans
and you know spouting their nonsense on
Fox News and stuff like almost sometimes
like I like hearing your input on those
things but when you replay the clips
before you give your input it's almost
like sometimes sometimes I can't even
listen to what these people have to say
like it's almost it makes me so sick
sometimes that like sometimes I fast
forward
even their Clips just so I can hear what
you have to say about it it's just that
nauseating you know what I mean like
well listen it's two things it's
basically two things one I am to some
degree desensitized by the insanity and
I I admit that it's not a good thing but
when you're exposed to this type of
insanity for a long time there's a
normalization that takes place and I'm
working against it but I know that I'm
desensitized to it to a degree and then
number two
um I I do think that taking a break from
this every single week and then longer
breaks every few months is important and
so when I'm done producing the Friday
show I don't even look at News until I
start prepping the Monday show so
there's like multiple days there where
people will say to me did you see this
did you see that I don't because I'm not
even paying attention to the news on
those days so I think scheduling that
and sticking to it is really important
okay yeah I I mean I guess that's just
all it's you know for a viewer like me
it's you know I can I can only take so
much per day before I have to like
literally shut it off because it's just
so just Bonkers like I totally
understand that I completely understand
that dude nothing no shame in that you
know yeah you'll play a Herschel Walker
clip and it's like I feel like I can
only sit through 15 seconds because it's
just so unbelievable no those are those
are pretty wacky I don't blame you there
my friend yeah all right uh I think
that's all okay thank you so much for
the call very much appreciate it uh
extremely powerful powerful stuff let's
go to Rey from North Carolina Ray
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
thank you David for having me
um
I was just asking uh someone who
analyzes uh news articles or watches
like um rallies for Mega candidates or
Trump for example is that I noticed that
there has been a focus on on trans
individuals and sports yes but what I've
noticed is that people mainly focus on
um mail or disciplines rather than the
female sport disciplines and it kind of
boggles my mind that I think maybe it
could be it's an easier
tactic to go after
um
trans
females and women's disciplines
um so it kind of how does that entail is
it just an easier way for them to
tear apart this topic yeah so here's the
deal you're bringing up a good question
which is they love to talk about someone
born biologically male competing in
women's weightlifting as an example or
women's swimming and there's a very
specific reason for that this is
basically a contrived issue so you take
the entire think about these as
concentric circles right okay so you've
got the biggest circle is
every issue that's out there within that
you have issues affecting uh American
politics within that you have social
issues within that you have lgbtq within
that you have trans issues within that
you have uh transports
to make that interesting which again is
it's it's a such a niche issue if you
talk about hey you know what this person
who was born biologically female and uh
identifies now as a man they want to try
out for men's uh ice hockey
all right well who cares let them I mean
it's like it's not a compelling story
it's not interesting let them try out
and most people would say if they're if
they're strong enough and physically big
enough and whatever to make the team let
let them play in the ice hockey who
cares so even Within
trans Sports you have to pick
essentially women's sports in which
physical size and strength makes a
difference and only focus on those there
are states like in South Dakota where
there is not even a single instance of
this being an issue as Scott Galloway
told us last week and they want to pass
laws about it so you are exactly right
they are picking what they believe to be
the most titillating
based on the idea of this six foot five
individual born biologically male
weightlifting against a five foot tall
woman or something like that because
they have to do that because most of the
examples we would all kind of go I don't
know it just seems fine who really cares
you know
yeah I agree with that but I would think
like um It's The Narrative of it could
be kind of if somehow uh
if an individual
um that was
um foreign
female and one in the male sports for
example uh wouldn't they themselves try
to be outraged by it or do you just
maybe they would I mean that would be
that would be super interesting like
imagine a situation where a trans man
competed in weightlifting in in the
men's weight lifting and one I don't
know what they would say they probably
would figure out a way to be outraged I
don't know they would say oh I don't
know what the performance enhancing
drugs or I don't know what they would
say it's an interesting question
yes uh something I've been looking into
recently for the past few years and
definitely taking notice to it with
Trump
um like saying no no mail and women's
sports in a sense that they only
highlight that issue in a lot of his
rallies as he just um exposes that all
the time and his women in men's sports
they seem to be fine with
exactly and I'm I'm curious to see how
this develops over time and thank you
for your input on this it's really
helped me out a little bit more Ray it's
been a pleasure Ray from North Carolina
great to speak to you we're going to
take a very quick break but we're going
right back to Discord and we're going to
hear from more people in a moment so
don't go anywhere
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
let's hear from a few more people via
the David Pacman show Discord which you
can find at davidpackman.com
Discord we are going to start right now
right away with no delay with Dylan from
Kentucky Dylan what is on your mind
today
hey David I've been a long time
listeners first time I've ever got to
call and speak to you so
I'll be a little shaky here you're doing
great so far my friend thank you friend
hey so I think for a long time it's sort
of been seen as the as the linchpin for
what might
uh fix you know
um our democracy here is is the issue of
campaign Finance reform
um and I wonder I would like to get your
thoughts on how that
can and will relate to the upcoming
Supreme Court decision on Moore versus
Harper and thus giving um
um
state legislators more power
over our our elections in general and I
would like to just uh mute and listen to
you uh talk about that for a moment so
one of the things uh when people call in
and they say David uh sir you know
sometimes they have tears in their eyes
and they say what do you think are the
most important issues facing American
politics uh the list that I've typically
given over the last few years is I say
campaign Finance is one such issue
media coverage of politics is another
issue and it's very much influenced by
how we Finance elections third is how we
run our elections meaning first past the
post in most cases and also the
Electoral College uh for the presidency
I would like to see but that changed and
fourth is climate change in the sense
that if your city is underwater or the
pollution in your city is so bad that
it's going to be hard to be an activist
for the issues that we care about unless
we deal with climate change in a in a
sensible way and then sometimes we'll
also talk about access to health care
because if you're sick and don't have
access to health care it's also hard to
be an activist whether you care about
education or abortion or whatever Access
to Health Care would also be another
issue I still stand by that but I think
that we need to be much more sort of
strategic when we simply say campaign
Finance reform I almost think it's too
broad for some people to understand what
we mean and so a much more specific but
still understandable set of of ideas
should be there and I think within that
the most important ones would be
public financing of Elections rather
than you know just unlimited spending
whatever you can raise you can spend so
public financing of Elections would be
number one
doing everything we can to eliminate the
ability of dark money to come in right
now even though they're quite strict
limits in terms of contributions
directly to candidates I forget whether
it's 2700 per cycle or or exactly what
the number is there is the ability to
donate huge amounts of money to packs
and the money can sort of be laundered
and you don't know who's spending what
where the money is coming from in all
cases necessarily so that's really where
I would would try to focus that
conversation and to be honest and I know
now I'm getting a little bit off the the
exact question I would like to see us
the left
become way more specific and strategic
with all of these issues so like for
example when we talk about climate
change okay climate change
we should be more specific in terms of
what we're talking about because
sometimes the things that are repeated
about climate change aren't really the
biggest concerns there's a really good
book called precipice by Toby ORD which
both argues I recently read the book
it's a couple years old it both argues
climate change is a massive issue that
we have to deal with and also some of
the statements made about it are a
little bit hyperbolic for example if
climate goes if it gets if the climate
gets warmer by two degrees on average
we're going to starve because we're not
going to be able to grow food when you
look into that actually it being a
little warmer would probably make it
easier to grow food in more parts of the
world the issues are different ones and
we should try to be more specific in all
of these uh all of these issues I hope
to some degree I'm answering the
question Dylan
um and uh I hope to hear uh from you
again very very soon let's go to Richard
from Jersey Richard welcome to the
program
hello David Pleasures they'd be speaking
with you the pleasure is all mine
so
um the thing on my mind right now
um I think a thing on a lot of people's
mind right now is for thinking it had to
be 2024 election and it seems to me that
the writing is on the wall I love the
status is more than likely going to be
the Republican nomination
and I keep thinking about the prospect
of Biden basic law detective and that
just seems to me like it's cool we're
starting to lose you the audio wasn't
great to start with it started at like a
six and a half but you're quite
literally just fading and cutting out
now so I heard you say you think
DeSantis will be the nominee for the
Republicans it's certainly possible I
don't know yet it's too early for me to
say that you were then starting to talk
about Biden and I just couldn't hear a
word you were saying
okay does that sound better yes it does
so my main thing is I don't think
Biden is gonna win against Rhonda
Sanchez okay but it's he's still toting
the line of saying that he is going to
run and the more time that goes on it
seems that he's going to so I'm
wondering what your thoughts are on is
it possible for him to change vice
presidency choice because Kamala Harris
herself isn't very popular either is it
possible to get a more exciting younger
Progressive candidate on the ticket with
him that could possibly bolster his
chances okay this is a good question if
Biden runs could he and should he
replace Kamala Harris his current VP
with someone else he absolutely could I
think the problem with that is whatever
benefit Biden might get from as you say
a more exciting or likable VP running
made in 24 could very easily be canceled
out by the fact that bailing on your VP
for consecutive terms might be seen as a
sign of trouble in Paradise for lack of
a better term so I don't know if I were
advising Biden that I would say to do
that I think you want to project
stability you want to project a steady
hand and part of that would be this this
is a good team and even if people are
changing behind the scenes you go with
the with the the person who is currently
VP also it would be very strange and
difficult and awkward to be campaigning
for several months while Kamala Harris
is still president with somebody else as
the running mate I think it raises I
think it creates problems for Biden to
do that
okay I I take your point that it would
be awkward but
I I my main thing with Biden is always
is that he's very low energy and even
though we were able to get past the
midterms pretty well I think it would
have been better if we had had a
president and a vice president that
inspires people to vote for something
instead of voting against the greater
evil and I I just I'm looking for things
that Democrats can do to do that for
younger voters and you know voters in
general I agree with you generally I
don't know that replacing Kamala is that
thing but I appreciate the the idea
fair enough thanks for speaking with me
David all right thank you for calling in
that's Richard from Jersey very very
powerful declarations there let's go to
Jeff from Pennsylvania Jeff welcome to
the program what's on your mind today
hey there uh first time caller uh this
is awesome Beyond thanks for picking me
thank you
um
I was wondering with all the talk
um about polling that we always hear
um this might be a dumb question but
where do people get pulled to collect
this info
you look at the methodology of each pole
and it will tell you that and it will
tell you the combination you know
typically it's landlines cell phones
sometimes there are online elements to
the poll but there's not one answer to
that and it's in the methodology
okay because I was thinking you know if
people are getting reached out to on
landlines and phones and I don't know
most people at this point don't pick up
for calls that are uh you know
suspicious or they don't recognize then
oh I don't know how much stock can you
put into polling in that case yeah your
your skepticism isn't new this is an
issue that people have talked about for
a while which is especially if it's only
landlines most polls are not only
landlines at this point in time I think
the bigger and more accurate concern
around polling is only certain people
are even going to entertain a call from
pollsters I mean listen I'm I'm so busy
for example I don't really talk on the
phone I don't even use my I barely use
my phone I have periods of time where
for hours I'm just away from my phone I
rarely pick it up I don't often I don't
even listen to voicemails I'm basically
like conducting business via email for
most of the things that I have going on
so it's true that there are only some
people who are even willing to get on
the phone with a pollster the way
pollsters deal with that is they adjust
their sample to account for that but
it's a fair question to say to what
degree can they really accurately and
fairly adjust the sample I think it's
fair polling has by and large still been
pretty accurate in most cases over the
last four years although we certainly
saw some specific instances in which it
was not so all good questions and
important things to ask
all right well that's what I had for
today thanks so much uh very much
appreciate the call
um let's see let's go to Elias from
Texas Elias welcome what's on your mind
today
hey David thanks for calling on me
um How could a 50 50 Senate differ from
a 51 to 49th Senate will Biden be able
to get more done with a simple majority
um I think that he will not get more
done but it will become irrelevant
whether both mansion and Cinema want to
go with what Democrats are trying to do
I've got a couple clips about this
um basically the the gist of it is when
it's 50 50 you need all 50 Democrats in
order to enable Kamala Harris to break
the tie if it's 5149 if Mansion doesn't
want to go with it it doesn't matter
anymore or if Cinema doesn't want to go
with it it doesn't matter anymore you
still get to 50 50 and Kamal is the
tiebreaker obviously if both mansion and
Cinema are resisting that's a different
story but it just gives you breathing
room
yeah
um and I was just curious about what
your efforts are in Georgia if you went
down there
um to go help out with Warnock
um personally I'm helping with tech
spanking tomorrow so
um yeah I am not going to be able to
make it down to Georgia but we are going
to be in these last few days
um pushing hard making sure everybody
knows about early voting we're going to
do some uh you know uniting around phone
and text banking events and uh we're
we're pushing as hard as we can there so
uh appreciate the questions and we let's
hope that's hope that Walker is defeated
there
right thank you David we're looking for
massive dumps of votes for Warnock all
right my friend
thank you very much okay Elias is uh
gone there very good uh all right let's
go to baz from the Netherlands baz
welcome to the program
hello
I had a question because I was somewhat
furious with a politician in my own
country
um a politician of my own party uh let's
say
um and I I got an email for
um in which he explained that um
um currently in our country uh our our
judges have the possibility to prohibit
uh organizations if they're dangerous to
the country
but that law
um excludes
political parties from being outlawed
he said that he would like to see that
changed and
for me that was like it
it it made something loosen me like uh I
got really mad over that
um but because I I think like that's
like the the opposite of the Democracy
even if
like
um
even if democratically it's decided you
want to end the Democracy I think that's
the purest form of democracy
um even though it's
weird
um boss I'm sorry I don't know that I'm
totally understanding what what you're
saying I'm I'm I certainly am not
following uh politics in Netherlands as
closely as maybe I would have to to
answer this question did you have a
question for me today
um
no not really them I guess no boss
listen I appreciate the call I just am
not as I'm not well versed enough in
Dutch politics and and I'm not sure and
it sounds like you don't really have a
question so let me look into what you're
mentioning okay
okay thank you thank you all right there
is boss from the Netherlands with a very
very powerful declaration let's go to
Nate from Rhode Island Nate welcome
what's on your mind today
hey David how you doing
doing well so I have a question so with
regards to the calls in the Discord it
may I make a suggestion for future calls
please
so there's something called uh stage
channels it's a new feature and
basically it's just what you said it
sounds like you have you the
yeah we're familiar with it Nate thank
you we've looked into it and it it was
not obvious from what we had and the
moderators determined that it really was
going to be an improvement and there it
raised a couple of new issues but we
will look into it again we're familiar
with stages all right and then just one
other thing so to add to what you've
been talking with uh Elias earlier about
um with regards to the Senate so in
addition with 51 Senate seats we have
subpoena power boost so we can start our
own investigations and also makes it
easier to Fast Track judges
yes absolutely when it comes to when it
comes to judges in particular now on
subpoena doesn't that depend on having a
majority in particular committees
correct me if I'm wrong
I'm too sure about I just read up on it
yeah because my understanding was and I
could be wrong Nate that the subpoenas
tend to come not from the Senate at
large but rather from specific
committees like the Judiciary and even
with a 50 50 majority they would still
have the majority in the Committees so
that was my understanding but I could be
wrong
yeah I'm not sure I'd have to look into
that thank you for bringing that up I'll
have to uh research that momentarily all
right all right Nate great to hear from
you appreciate it thank you for so much
for taking my call have a oh and then he
is gone uh all right thank you everybody
for calling in we're going to go to a
break we will take more calls next week
and it's going to be a beautiful thing
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's get to emails the Friday mailbag
you can email info davidpackman.com
sometimes we'll include a tweet or a
YouTube comment or whatever today we're
starting with a Facebook message and it
is a pretty ugly one this one is from
James James writes your
a very misinformed [ __ ] now your is
y-o-u-r it's almost a requirement if you
write trumpist hate mail that you use
the wrong your okay you're a very
misinformed [ __ ] I have never seen
Trump shocked about anything Democrats
have tried the Democrats are scared of
trump because they can't control him as
they control Biden that's because he
doesn't want the truth is their response
to a message saying by the way David
can't respond to you individually this
is a really common thing we see
for many of these Mega people
which is Democrats are scared of trump
the problem with dealing with Democrats
are scared of trump is of course you
know and I know it's not scared of trump
it's horrified at what a disaster he is
and the truth is
it is scary the things Trump would do if
allowed to do them they use the word
scared in a very different way they use
scared to mean intimidated by just
overwhelmed with Trump's masculinity and
intelligence and drive and all these
things that make absolutely no sense to
feel about Donald Trump no we're
horrified in the way that you're scared
of really serious illness or a fascist
dictator or you know whatever the case
may be
um but of course good luck explaining
that to them and why is it always the
wrong Yore can someone explain to me why
that is I would love to understand it
Michael wrote In
Michael wrote about coverage of the
Colorado shooting and said hey David
I've been a listener for a while but I'm
curious about why you haven't covered
the Colorado shooting I've listened to
both Monday and Tuesday shows following
the weekend shooting and I cannot recall
your coverage of this thanks Mike so
there's there's two things going on with
my coverage of shootings and I'm glad to
sort of change my perspective if it
makes sense to change it number one is
there are so many shootings in the
United States
and so many of them are mass shootings
and so many of them are happening in
ways that are motivated by the I certain
identity factors which is sort of what
we call hate crimes right targeting
lgbtq people or Jewish people or
whatever the case may be
that it's sometimes hard to find
something new to say about them and
I sometimes feel like I don't have
anything to say about these shootings
because they are so common that's one
thing
second thing is in particular when there
are some of the really big shootings
they get a lot of media attention
a lot of the early information is often
wrong
and with certain breaking stories
you still report on them early
because they are unique stories and
while of course every single one of the
victims of a mass shooting is unique we
don't go well there have been other
people killed in mass shooting so the
victims don't matter no that's not what
I'm saying but what I am saying
is that because this the circumstances
repeat themselves time and time again
uh I find it less useful to just report
what we know three hours in or whatever
the case may be so we ended up talking
about the shooting on Wednesday this
email came in about Monday Tuesday we
talked about the shooting on Wednesday
that's why I sometimes am deliberately
slower in reporting on some of these
mass shootings people want them reported
on more quickly I'm willing to do it I
just don't know how much I have to add
particularly when we don't yet have the
full story Michael wrote in about
evidence-based medicine and says David
great start to Monday's show explaining
the risks of cardiac complications from
vaccines compared to risks from covid
you explain things clearly calmly and
with a high level of expertise thanks
sadly the people who would most benefit
from your charitable sharing either
won't understand it or won't listen yes
that is often the case on another note
it is unfortunate you have to waste your
time answering Critics on your show but
on the other hand you do acknowledge
your critics and that is more than
Hannity Carlson Jones O'Reilly or the
others on the right will do keep up the
good work it really matters thank you
Michael no comment just presented
without comment very much appreciate
that message
Teresa wrote in with a request that I've
gotten from many people Teresa said hey
David can you give members access to
your soundboard pretty please best
Teresa oh the bonus show where you want
to make make money everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad
yeah you all know the sound board so
here's the deal with the sound board I
would love to set up as a feature for
our members that's a great bonus feature
an extra feature
access to the sound board that I have
here for the show
I don't know how to achieve that from a
technical perspective
I guess we need some kind of a web-based
soundboard system
that is maybe password protected or
unlisted in some way so here's my
thought if anybody out there knows how I
can do what Teresa is asking which is
make access to my soundboard a premium
member feature if you can tell me how to
do it I will do it and I think that that
would be a really cool thing to be able
to offer Melissa wrote in about YouTube
and Melissa says we watch your program
every night in our home well thank you
Melissa Melissa adds I've blocked out
when you talk about subscribing to your
YouTube channel only because we don't
watch you on YouTube we watch your
program on Free Speech TV
I have since come to my senses and
subscribed thank you for all the work
you and your team do to keep us informed
Melissa from Wisconsin thank you Melissa
yeah listen
even if you watch on another platform if
you want to do us a very small and
completely free favor if you have any
kind of account
with Google YouTube Etc
subscribe to the channel it really helps
us we're working to 2 million
subscribers you go to youtube.com slash
the davidpackman show quick easy and
very important Justin wrote in about
this idea of executing drug dealers that
summon the Maga right including the
failed former president Donald Trump
have started fixating on Justin writes I
find it interesting Trump is saying all
convicted drug dealers should be
executed and not specifying what drugs
you need to be caught dealing or
trafficking in order to get executed is
he saying people convicted of dealing
cannabis should be executed serious
question I think he is saying that quite
frankly I think he is saying that
because he's not making any distinction
and I mean listen I guess we have to ask
him it's often very hard to know what it
is exactly that Trump is suggesting
but he doesn't seem to be making any
distinction
as far as which drugs the dealing of
should get you executed but the most
important thing is it's completely
hypocritical because remember that even
though Donald Trump is now saying drug
dealers are such a Scourge or Scourge as
he used to say during the covet era that
they should be killed
he also pardoned a bunch of drug dealers
on his way out of office so maybe not a
shock to some of you
that he's a bit of a hypocrite okay last
thing Dylan wrote to me a message called
on judgment
and tells me that in the following text
he will attempt to explain the principle
of non-judgment
and why he believes it to be a just
tenet on which to base our relations
with others he then sent pages and pages
of all sorts of biblical talk that is so
long-winded that I couldn't even fit it
on the screen
do not send me this stuff
it is not being read by anybody we have
a message on our website on the contact
page which says email in your message
will be read but me David I can't
necessarily read every email and I
certainly can't respond to them but
someone's going to read it
no one is reading this stuff
Dylan no one is reading pages and pages
of biblical
mumbo-jumbo about non-judgment it's just
not getting read it's not relevant to
the show please please please just don't
bother because you're wasting your time
and now you've wasted my time and the
audience's time with me explaining
that it's not going to be dealt with
okay so please know more other emails
info davidpackman.com we've got a great
bonus show for you today sign up at
joinpakman.com get instant access and of
course the coupon code 24 starts now is
available also the free white paper on
arguing politics and changing Minds is
available at davidpackman.com guide I
will update you next week on the number
of downloads but I am quite ready to
call it a success
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the most
comfortable men's boxers and t-shirts
you'll ever find are at leisure of NYC
their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers feel as
light as air and their silky smooth
supima cotton crewneck t-shirts are
amazing I love them you'll get 15 off
with code Pacman at davidpackman.com NYC